what people would consider cheating
right sex where cheating starts way
before that does it start with
objectifying does it start with
messaging other people liking Instagram
posts stuff like that but imagine if we
counted women flirting as cheating does
it start with posting provocative
provocative pictures on Instagram I like
that one I'm not saying he has to be 100
traditional I just prefer monogamy in my
relationship okay I as Christine I think
monogamy is Sexy And I like being with
one person and I like that one person
why have you picked cheaters oh what up
guys welcome to the just pearly things
YouTube channel and welcome to my
reaction series before I start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that notification Bell the way
you're gonna be notified of my daily
videos like the video on your way and
let's get started today we have the
newest Talent at the audacity Network
all right it's just us two you know all
of the talents here but if you want to
join DM me on Instagram just pearly
things one we're looking for like two or
three more talents in London over the
next couple months no hurry though but
tell me why you're talented
um make sure you guys go subscribe to
Christine's Channel where you're doing
these essay videos yeah yeah uh
basically taking a look at the mess
Society currently has going on and uh
just trying to bring people's awareness
to that mess and why I don't necessarily
think it's in our best interests but hey
think any different why don't you go
check out and let me know yeah I'm wrong
yeah argue with her we're probably gonna
have you do some streams to maybe
calling shows or something yeah
um all right guys today we're reacting
um to Black Ice podcast I actually went
on this podcast when I was in Vegas
talking about some of the issues in
modern relationships so um you want to
pull up stop punching air king king's
punching air you know
all right
um live debate traditional men versus
modern women we're waiting to talk about
here is the toxic traits that can come
about on both sides of the relationship
right right let's say we find the ideal
person however that ideal person is a
high value man right and as in the teal
the the teaser that we cut you know you
said high value men have options
um how would you define cheating in a
relationship and I'm going to ask you
the same thing are you coming to me
first yeah wow this is fun okay so what
I meant by that was like when we're
talking about look cheat is cheating I
don't condone it okay I'm not for it I
was using a comparison analogy if a
woman cheats a woman and I say this and
this is actually a benefit for women
very few women go oh I need to go get
some dick I'm going to go [__] somebody
women aren't like that women want to
build an emotional connection and I
respect that and also they they want to
get to know the guy men what I said when
men cheat is not as bad hear me out hear
my heart now my words this is where you
have to have thick skin and a soft heart
if I'm in love with a woman and I'm a
high value man remember biological we
would put here on Earth for one reason
to procreate seven billion people in the
world weren't all built by being
monogamous okay they just weren't now
I'm not condoning it what I'm saying is
this if I go out and I'm in love and
with a woman in a relationship and all
of a sudden Here Comes you know the
highest thing since apple pie right
whatever you could pick an actress you
can make Kim Kardashian if you think
shot I don't care who it is and she is
an opportunity where a man's put in that
situation and he and he he slams it he
hits it [__] her right does he not love
his woman any less no she didn't mean
[__] to him it was a desire and a need
that was biologically wired into him if
a woman does it she's built uh some type
of connection with a man she's been
talking to man over time it was a work
husband it was that guy friend that was
on standby sometimes I think we project
our feelings onto men so like because if
we were to cheat it would be an
emotional connection yeah we think like
if men were to cheat it would be an
emotional connection yeah we project
that they would have the same mentality
as us correct I I like that's what I've
noticed was a lot of time the same way
like women think men want like women
with money it's so true I remember the
first time I got cheated on like
straight away I was like well you you
must just just now be in love with them
and I mean nothing like yeah well and a
lot of times like I think this is more
honest like I I think it's better we
know you know men are kind of hardwired
through anything yeah and that might
happen because when you're dishonest
it's like you know then it kind of gives
us expectations the men may not be able
to meet if we go after a certain type of
guy also we're kind of hurting ourselves
more by telling ourselves that men work
the same as women because you know
things do happen like he just said it's
a biological Instinct for men so if
those things do happen and we're sitting
here saying well they're the same as us
you're hurting yourself more because
you're telling yourself that that meant
more to him than it actually did yeah
and then it's like she was just hot
there willing
she was hot they're available and I'm
not like I don't people always think I'm
condoning cheating but I'm really not
it's just just acknowledging a fact of
reality it happens and it's like you
kind of just gotta pick your poison you
know they're like do you want to be
cheated on them like you know I hope I'd
like to not be you know that's the goal
but you know life is life one day you're
gonna be 55 and not that hot to your
husband a 35 year old single baby mama
might come by and just be like I I'm
here and ready and I'm like well
Orbiter waiting around it's 10 times
worse because she didn't just go out one
day and say oh look at this hot sexy uh
Jason Momoa he wants to [__] me it
doesn't work like that it does not work
like that it's very rare but guys you
take a 10 which is paid for her looks
famous model and she's in a room in
lingerie nine times out of ten the
dude's gonna hit the Skins oh you don't
let me know he still loves his woman but
he's wired differently I'm not saying
it's right but I'm saying that's the
facts in the reality and I deal with
multi-multi-millionaires seven eight
nine figure men I'm counseling a famous
rapper I hear the stories I know what's
going on and so I'm here to share with
you the facts and the reality that when
you're dealing with high value men the
chances of monogamy are slim very slim
because he has all the options he wants
because all the women are competing for
him and then I'll be like okay just date
a guy that makes 35
000 pounds a year an average yeah an
average guy and the ladies are like ah
no no I can't do that and I'm like look
at I'm not saying I I'm not I'm saying
pick what you want go for what you want
like I'm all for you know I I know we we
[__] on delusional women but I actually
have no problem of with women going for
the top percent of men if they're
putting in work you know what I mean and
doing it strategically my my issue is
like when they're fatties yeah and it's
just like I mean look it stranger things
have happened go for what you want but
know what comes with it and let's not
live in this La La Land and know your
your chances of success your chances of
success aren't going to be very high so
don't then don't get disappointed and
blame them play the lottery
like like I don't have any problem with
women buying lottery tickets but I have
a problem with women saying lottery
tickets are evil if it doesn't work out
yeah
if you line up a hundred guys ten
percent of those men are [__] other
90 aren't and when we think oh they're
all these guys are no they're not
they're not even having sex women have
more access to men like never before
right now with all the social media and
I don't and so hold on hold on you're an
attractive woman okay fair to say if you
got on the phone right now you could go
have sex right now do you know how hard
it is for a man very difficult very
difficult and even a a mediocre looking
woman of four she can do that a three
guys unless you have a blue check mark
and you're Drake it's very hard to step
out and say hey I'm gonna get laid
tonight you know what I mean so go ahead
yeah so I mean you took it to the the
length of like what people would
consider cheating right sex now I feel
like maybe this might come from a
woman's side where cheating starts way
before that does it start with
objectifying does it start with
messaging other people liking Instagram
posts stuff like that but imagine if we
counted women flirting as cheating does
it start with posting provocative
provocative pictures on Instagram I like
that one oh because you're advertising
what what to offer it's you know it's a
bit
and that's like if we counted that as
cheating women would women are already
out cheating men but imagine if we
counted like flirting having a work has
been accepting attention from other men
we would oh my God having your boobs out
yeah the things women wear these days in
relationships you'll be you'll be you'll
be scared pretty good explanation
how do you feel I I feel like I mean I
think there's men that could agree with
this too that cheating doesn't start at
sex like I think cheating starts way
before sex actually happens sometimes
and what you were saying as far as like
the I don't want to say it's validation
because I know you didn't not condone it
and I've never thought you've condoned
cheating like I've talked to you before
but when you kind of like give that like
reasoning out loud to somebody I feel
like it's really hard because you're not
talking about you're not talking about
communicating with your partner that you
need to be in an open relationship and
this is just what you do and this is
what your needs are cheating is betrayal
cheating is going behind something I
know but I think sometimes the stripper
just comes on to them and they're like
it's there you know what it's like it's
not that they they they're saying this
is probably gonna happen it's just that
some things do happen hardy hardy came
up to him yeah I mean she said cheating
is betrayal is complaining about your
partner to another man betrayal
yeah
it depends what you're complaining about
doesn't it like like I don't know if it
does unless like a brother maybe that's
literally giving information about your
mother if you're like if you're
complaining sound like a male friend
yeah a male friend 100 that's about that
and literally doing something to them
that can completely alter their state of
reality for the rest of their life on
how they see things how they develop how
they see relationships turning into
masculine women you know there's so much
that can happen there from betrayal and
on the counter part two men getting
cheated on I some of my best friends
have had that happen to them and it
scarred them and it's hurt them for a
very very very long time so cheating in
general hurts okay you know yeah so I
know what I get what you get I feel like
getting hurt is a choice I know this is
like a weird okay I like it I I I feel
like see but then I think of like
extreme scenarios but like let's just
take the cheating both ways like you
could either choose to let that hurt you
for years or you can just say it was
what it was take the L and move on our
grandmothers used to take L's and move
on you know they'd be like oh [__] he's
got a family across town like do you
know what I mean they want to go to the
internet and do this sob story or poor
me like we just need to learn learn to
take L's and I'm not even saying I've
been perfect I've absolutely taken else
and not moved on and you know who would
hurt me yeah me like we just need to
take the owl I'm definitely not the same
thing you hurt yourself more generally
again let's disregard the extremes
generally in in our lives that we live
in Western life or whatever you hurt
yourself so much more than anything on
the outside is actually high and have
you ever okay have you ever had someone
mad at you but you didn't know
especially with women like you didn't
know they were mad and it's so crazy
because when you talk to them you're
like oh hi and they're like
and it's like it's like they were so and
they may be what they're mad over a
valid reason or whatever it was but it's
like they've let the anger like Fest us
yeah like faster and like that's when I
realized I'm like anger is actually like
I almost think it's like
addicting yeah and it's like the high
and the low and that's like what we get
addicted to and I'm like it faster than
you're the one who suffers not bam yeah
yeah because I don't care and then it's
like you get your like release with
either like you know the sob story on
Instagram yeah or like the lashing out
at the person yeah yeah we like I think
it's from the Kardashians about how
women cheat from an emotional standpoint
normally if they're cheating it's
because something's been going on in
their relationship emotionally where
they're not fulfilled and they're
starting to try to find that normally if
they're men normally if the women are
cheating it's the man's fault never no
accountability ever oh it's because the
man wasn't doing something for the
relationship but instead of
communicating like an adult that my
needs weren't being met I decided to go
off and sleep with someone else don't I
don't like that already filled with
somebody else sure which is deeper than
just something physical yeah I
completely agree with that but I don't
think that it hurts less because the
betrayals that I've had in my life
scarred the [__] out of me oh absolutely
you know what I mean and it's not so
much even the physical act it's what
went into that you know so I think that
statement flares up a lot of emotions
because it's like well [__] is he saying
that like because I'm a woman and my guy
cheated on me just say whatever because
it's a physical skin on skin act it
still does damage and I think that's
where there's because of what she's
ensuring on that from her own
perspective as a woman she doesn't even
realize that she's hurting herself more
with what she's saying no you know it's
funny I've talked to chicks that are in
one-sided open relationships and it's so
funny that's when I realized getting
hurt was a choice because I saw them
just like not be hurt by it at all now
don't get me wrong it doesn't always
work yeah women are we are we're
emotional creatures but I realized she
was like yeah I don't care yeah yeah
like and I'm not saying like you're
obviously gonna have jealousy it's gonna
happen but it's like I just realized
like letting it fester and getting mad
and like putting our own psychological
spin I started to realize what we do to
men when women started doing it to me
like they would just start
psychoanalyzing me and giving me these
like mental like narcissists or like all
this [__] and I'm like oh my God this is
what we would do to our boyfriends we'd
be like oh and like it hurts us because
we just spend all this time like it just
turns into craziness yeah yeah crazy
ladies that's why I call them on Twitter
I'll just be like crazy lady hard so
would it be would it be fair to say you
want a traditional man in a relationship
right would it be fair to say you're a
traditional woman that I don't know if I
can full okay fully say that like 100
like you know you're saying like you can
agree with someone for the most part yes
okay but would a traditional woman what
if a guy said for the most part yes for
being a traditional just like a note her
body half naked on Instagram see that's
where I okay but hear me out and he said
cheating liking something if you're
showing your body to men on the daily
okay and I don't have a problem with
what you do but you're exposing yourself
in a sexual way right you're condoning
that I think it's based on the
partnership I think your partner would
have to really okay but you want a
traditional man she never had any based
on a partnership when we're talking
about demands cheating but as soon as we
start talking about the women then now
there are all these terms and conditions
you want a traditional man but see this
is a problem with a lot of modern day
women they don't want to be a
traditional woman but I do okay so if
you were the man the love of your life
and he was the perfect guy that you you
created God broke the mold if you
believe God or not I'm not here to
appreciate it and that's the guy says
Christina you're loving me you do
anything for yep I'll do anything for
you you do anything for me I want you to
to close your Instagram account would
you do it if I didn't have to rely on
Instagram for work and this was the
perfect scenario where I knew this was
my husband but see it's like they've
programmed us to always want a backup
plan that's like the last hundred years
all the propagandas you can't rely on a
man you have to have a backup plan the
man cannot be also the floor and the
logic if I didn't have to rely on
Instagram you don't have to rely on
Instagram you could go out and get a job
like the rest of us you can go out and
work in McDonald's 80 hours a week you
don't have to rely on Instagram I used
to sell car we both used
oh that's kind of funny looking we're
like copier sales vets go sell copiers
chick apart from that she did it's
almost like she didn't hear the question
yeah they said if you have your perfect
man and then she still started an answer
with if I didn't have to rely on
Instagram literally if you have your
perfect man you don't need money I don't
know but it's that it's that programming
that instantly it's like Oh well man
money because it all just like this
checklist of like okay man money car
marriage kids like instead of actually
seeing value in things it's just
straight to to money and materialism and
this is going to be our life and he
wasn't taking away my passions which I
have to be online for competing I have
to be online for my podcast I have to be
doing things with my physical body for
my career sure I would not take away
what makes me Christina you know what I
was thinking you have to take away What
Makes You Christina when you have
children because like it's all with her
body and you you have to carry the kid
that's what she sees she just said it
you'd be taking away what makes me me so
she's saying what makes her her is what
she does on the internet and what she
does with her body that's all she is
she's a flesh suit on on pixels on a
screen she's just showed herself she has
no inner value she just sees herself as
a body and a page but you're not being
traditional like I said I don't think
I'm a hundred percent a traditionalist
there are Traditional Values that I like
in my relationships but I can't tell you
that I'm a traditional person because no
there are Traditional Values that I like
every man to have that I do not wish to
reciprocate to me that's like taking
away my Essence okay but why would you
take that away from a man why should he
be traditional to you I'm not saying he
has to be 100 traditional I just prefer
monogamy in my relationship okay I as
Christine I think monogamy is Sexy And I
like being with one person and I like
that one person and why have you picked
cheaters that's the question and why do
you allow your thousands of followers to
see monogamous man should only be suit
me sexually since day one since the dawn
of time men even even like Solomon had
700 wives 300 concubine men have never
been monogamous we just were forced that
way by by social the social Society
right biblically morally or ethically
yeah I'm not here to to say anything but
I'm just saying if that guy's
traditional he's going to be loyal to
you see you're you're not my point is
this is you're you're trying to find
this guy or maybe you have that guy but
then you're not willing to give up what
it takes to to you see it's not a fair
exchange I never said I wouldn't be able
to give up certain things to me in the
middle for the relationship that I want
to be in that's providing me the
container that I would like if that
either like me and my boyfriend
currently have had these discussions
about certain things because
it's probably gonna be another one me
and my boyfriend currently the current
one that's like when you say are you
gonna marry are you guys gonna stay
together forever well I hope I hope so
yeah what do you mean I'm sorry are you
are you gonna like you even know that
you're sticking around or not like you
can say or maybe they're saying I hope
so on like oh maybe he might leave me
but I don't think it's that I think it's
them saying to themselves like oh I
don't know we're gonna meet in the
middle because there to me is no like
black and white way to run relationships
anymore there really isn't there's so
many ways whether it's open whether it's
80 20 whether it's completely monogamous
where it's polyamory it's like there's
so many ways so you really have to find
what works for you and your partner that
may be combining some traditional
ideologies with also some more maybe
off-the-cuff ways of living so what
traditional aspects are you gonna bring
and for me my partner is not intimidated
with the way I am on Instagram it
doesn't bother him but there are lines
and there are boundaries that I would
never cry I always know that the woman's
crazy when she starts bringing up like
these feminist terms like boundaries
like I know like that's just like
therapy speak that the feminist just
infiltrated the therapy system to just
confuse everybody here's the thing like
you can always tell a man's character
from his woman's Behavior if a woman
says my mind is okay with this and this
like when it pertains to things that are
clearly not socially acceptable in a way
he just tells me that one that man is is
a simple one and then it tells me that
she's the one that wears the pants in
relationship because the reality is I
know my sound weird some people might
say oh that's that's misogynistic but
reality is if a woman finds a man that
checks all her boxes there is no way on
Earth that she can get in a relationship
with him on her terms that's really true
and I would never do that because I know
it would upset him so we have to kind of
meet in the middle with certain things
that's why all these stupid dating
advice books for women don't work where
they're like the three-month rule or
like all the like like the like all the
it's like all these manipulation tactics
basically to control men and like sell
you for a higher price than you are
because all of them it's like the guys
that you want those are not going to
work on that's only going to work on
like simp man yeah cause like it's all
all the and I can't think of any off the
top of my head but I'm just thinking
like the Matthew hussies the Steve
Harvey's the all of those guys it's just
like to get men on your terms but you
have to be on his it's crazy because
women do like a lot of men don't see
these correlations if you can if you can
get a man to succumb to your every wish
what makes you think another woman can
do the same thing yeah yeah yeah yeah
wow
like that should be the first thing that
should make you realize that should be a
red flag yeah if you can get him to do
anything then one you're not the most
beautiful man on Earth two you're not
the most intelligent woman on earth so
if you that you are basically average
can get a man to do all of that then the
very next girl can basically come and
take him from you and also it should be
like an indication if he's accepting of
things that could potentially put you in
a situation where you're potentially at
harm like she's saying on my man's okay
with I think she's referring to like the
things she posts and that it's like well
if I went home and told my boyfriend I'm
planning on going on holiday with five
single girls who all are known for
posting their bodies all over Instagram
and like to sleep around and he said to
me great go have fun I trust you I trust
I'd be like okay right let's go with
that you trust me but you as a man are
sat there saying that you also trust the
world out there and there I'm like no no
no no you should you should want your
man to be thinking about you in every
situation and a lot of it's just naive
like these guys are naive they don't
understand female nature that's why I
like shows like this are so important
and like fresh and fit like all those
guys because like they might not like
people don't like the way they deliver
the message but it's like is it true or
is it not true the message is true you
know what's funny I'm always like the
approved friend like for vacations like
with married with I think like it's it's
so deep that okay now we're talking
about relationships I think yeah the
relationship thing is is has gotten
really bad but I even I weep for men
that have that same Dynamic with their
daughters that is the worst one for me
like obviously in relationships you can
argue that yeah we're all adults and
this and that so yeah but with a father
should never under any circumstance let
his daughter like have free reign to do
whatever she wants to do correct as long
as she's underneath his authority in his
house feeding off of him in fact not
just his daughter his sons
fathers should never allow their
children to do whatever they want to do
as far as like traditional roles as like
if I if this became a marriage let's
just say and we got into a position
where he's like I don't want you to have
to bartend anymore I don't want you to
have to cocktail anymore if that
container was able to provide me with
that shelter to know I'm safe a hundred
percent but I've also been in
relationships where I let all of those
guards down I became that person that
took care of completely everything at
home basically the traditional role I
still did had a part-time job but that
backfired in my [__] face because I
lost all my sense of self all of who I
was the ways I the ways that got fired
what really happened tell us the real
story why did you really break up what
went wrong what broke down it's not
because you gave up a bunch of things
like what happened that's sad because
she picked a loser she picked the wrong
guy that's that's why honest you lost
your sense of self also we've already
derived that this lady's sense of self
is determined by how she views her body
and her Instagram so maybe that's what
she had to do and she wasn't happy with
it good catch yeah she lost her
Instagram just take a break Christina
rely on me and then that should happen
so you kind of have to take things a
little bit slower before you allow
somebody to take complete control you
have to just like you have to ease into
it you know what I mean like you can't
just be also you can't just be a woman
and be like he's got it sure with like
six months 12 months of knowing them and
like yeah he makes he makes all this
money and he has these cars and that's
okay we want we want all of the upside
of marriage with none of the risks
that's the thing you will never be a
hundred percent sure about a person
every person has character flaws nobody
is perfect you're not perfect they're
not perfect but we want all of the
upside of a lifetime of security but
with none of the risk men have all of
the risks and women don't even want to
give up their like Instagram yeah and
because that's like a backup for women
yeah yeah yeah
because they see that as their their
only way of having a livelihood instead
of actually having to work you know
what's funny and I I ask girls this
question they'll be like for work I'm
like how much do you make off of it and
then they're like oh I don't make
anything like all right all right take
care of me he's not gonna let me fall
and just believe it anymore because
unfortunately why is it that um because
what you said is very much the case no
one's perfect you know everyone is going
to have flaws where did this idea of the
amount of time that you've been with
someone determines whether the
relationship is going to succeed or not
I think it's actually the opposite what
do you mean like I think I know it's
like if you've lived with someone before
your chance of divorce goes up yeah but
I I think it's like there's a certain
amount of time it like decreases your
chance of marriage I don't I don't
remember what it was I'm butchering the
study but you know okay you know what I
was thinking about all right if you
think sex is or sexist to men as
attention is to women think about how
men all right imagine if men were were
paid to watch porn how how bad men would
but now we have it that women are paid
to get attention from men isn't that
interesting yeah yeah because it's like
if the men if we had a cash prize for
watching porn men would watch porn all
the time I'm not already what like it's
already a problem right but imagine if
there's a cash prize at the end but
women it's like we have a cash prize at
the end with like only fans yeah and
other like putting our bodies online
which we already naturally want to do
anyway like we naturally want to get
attention from the opposite gender yeah
but there's a cash prize it's like an
incentive too yeah and same with
Instagram
but the prize instead of cash is
attention yeah yeah likes yeah like
imagine if men like actually got to have
sex with the with the models like the
porn whatever chicks they would do it
all the time yeah but women actually get
attention from high status men from
Instagram yeah and that's why we're so
bad you know are a lot of unhealed
people who don't know how to have that
feminine woman that they say they want
without stomping all over her right but
you you CH you choose that too you
choose who you're with oh 100 I'm just
saying you have to be careful when
entering in relationships I just want to
hear a girl say she did anything wrong
in a relationship other than give too
much that's it like because it's not
just like you can give it all up because
then you're left with nothing and
they're moving on to the next younger
prettier fitter person because you know
what I'm kind of done with her and then
it sounds really personal because that
what happened like yeah well first of
all if you're married you're left with
about 70 percent from my experience when
a woman says she give too much in a
relationship she was pretending the
whole time yeah if you're naturally a
giver you wouldn't even remember all the
things you give and it's like you're
keeping score yeah that's what it means
like because if you naturally give a
like bro growing up my mom I can and
this is why like it's almost like the
karma follows me when everywhere I go
growing up I can't count how many people
my mom actually fed like you you just
come to the house this food but you will
never hear my mom say oh my God I gave I
gave so much I did this no like it's
just how she was raised we were raised
in a way where when you're cooking you
make sure that anybody that's present in
the vicinity gets to eat it was the same
with my mom everyone knows my house when
you come to my house my mom is going to
feed you but you don't you don't really
I don't know of my friends who it's like
oh like they're gonna cook for everyone
I said if you're married if you're
married if you're not and you're in a
relationship with me my girlfriend I put
her in my trust because we're like we're
married but we're not with a contract
but see he's you're giving you're giving
her a safety right like you're providing
a container for her where she can trust
you but if you're not married like you
just said you're married then it is
about money because there's a
contractual agreement with the state and
you're guaranteed money and so women say
it's not about money it is about money
it's about security it is about security
that's my point so anytime you're out
there looking for that perfect fit it's
always about hey how how secure am I
going to be financially well you have to
think about those things and that
requires a lot of money yeah and I think
that there's like maybe this is the side
where we talk to women about the things
to look out for too because looks aren't
going to just be it for you just because
he has a nice car and the looks doesn't
mean that's going to be your perfect fit
I find and this is the problem and where
I'm trying to figure out why this is
happening on the men's side at least is
there are men who convince or not
convinced they get in relationships with
women and say they want a monogamous
relationship right they you're you're it
you're the one I'm monogamous to you but
then they change their mind they start
cheating behind her back okay can I can
I ask you a question with these men are
these what type of men are you talking
about well and this is this is what I'm
getting at like when you define a true
healthy alpha male these are not them
and when I like how they shame like like
who are women to decide what a true
healthy alpha male is you don't get to
decide that like what do we determine as
healthy Alpha let's just be honest the
alpha done in history were definitely
[__] a bunch of chicks they were
absolutely doing that let's not let's
not live in this La La Land like some
people get attached to it's like yeah
I'm an alpha male and they have no idea
what that means they have no idea how to
be that how to be open honest with
themselves and communicate with their
partner what they actually need because
I'll tell you what if my partner had
told me Christina I can't be monogamous
I need multiple partners to be happy I
would have chose not to be with this
person yeah but where are the lies he
also wasn't that old of a man he was a
younger man true okay but problem number
one thing that doesn't happen with older
men too because no it does it does but
it also based on the option I'll say
this with with clear transparency and
when I say high value man he's got a
he's got a network a circle of influence
of individuals that look at him for
guidance and advice he's got a network
of individuals that are worth millions
of dollars he's a leader he's a leader
okay 95 of those men are going to see
other women you you have to accept that
or don't and that's okay I'm not telling
you to accept it I'm not telling you
except I'm telling you the truth most
these guys why do you think the strip
clubs do so good in Vegas 90 of men in
there are married 90 it's not that they
don't love their wives but the reality
is they are going to see other women and
you either accept if and I'm not talking
about you Christine I'm talking about if
Drake came in here right now and asked a
girl hey I want to start dating you you
know I'm seeing other girls she wouldn't
think twice about it she wouldn't think
twice I would you would right but ninety
percent of the women shut uh cap cap
capity capital
that's so much cup because cash she
hasn't even dated anybody on Drake's
level but I'm sure they've all the
people she did that I've seen other
women it's all on Drake like oh he's got
a girlfriend it's okay he's taking me
out now is that really a high quality
woman it doesn't that's what they do
those are the bad women man those are
the matter it's what he wants but here's
my point I know I'm just asking your
opinion but here it's almost like a
mating strategy it's like I am a better
woman because I would be I would deny
Drake even though I haven't opened
Instagram profile like it's like here's
my here's my point my point is this is
that you need but it doesn't and they
missed the point too it's like it
doesn't have to be Drake we use Drake
because he [__] a lot of chicks and
he's a very well-known guy that sleeps
that's a big Playboy but we could
substitute whatever Playboy you want
there's some guy you would accept
non-monogamy from let's just call it
what it is Jesse Williams call me I'm
just kidding but like but you know who
is he was like my teenage Crush when I
was a kid when I was a kid and I was
like he's in Gray's Anatomy that was
like when I was younger I'm gonna have
to look him up I have no idea yeah but
it's like it's like it's like the the
the exception doesn't prove the rule we
can we can put in a rich businessman or
whatever it is most women have a guy
they'd accept it from or at least and
then like the other thing is even if
they're faithful it's like okay their
work is gonna get the best of them
you're still not gonna get the attention
from them yeah they're probably gonna
have a work wife like you know it's not
you know maybe they're not sleeping
together but you don't get like the the
family man yeah yeah yeah you know no
the reality okay don't go for the high
top 10 men don't that's okay and it
doesn't mean an average guy is bad but
you have to you're it's either a or b I
just think it's I think it's kind of
screwed up to call an a guy average who
is like maybe not the top ten percent no
no when I say average he doesn't have
the accessibility to those women that
high value men do that's the difference
that's the difference when I say that
and and hear me out like I told you ten
percent of men are actually have access
to they're the only ones out there
having they're sexually active it is
what it is yeah no I've I've seen the
studies I've right I've seen videos I
know what you're talking about so I just
feel like there's a gray area there is a
gray area but but I'm just telling you I
just feel I feel to expect from a
reality perspective again when I say I'm
not con I'm not condoning it but you're
also speaking to a woman too who is not
a money Chaser like I'm not that person
that chases I'm not a money Chaser but I
am gonna tell you that the reason why
I'm not willing to fully commit to a
relationship if it involves taking down
my Instagram and my body is because it
makes me money she's literally
contradicting herself doesn't make any
sense well it's like all right two guys
equally the same one makes uh 500k one
makes 40. who are you picking like shut
up like shut up like come on it's like
if they're exactly the same you're gonna
pick the one that makes more money just
like if two chicks are exactly the same
one's hotter and one's ugly or they're
gonna pick the hotter one it's just like
it is worse than yeah it's like water is
wet the sky is blue but we've lived in
such delusion in that's saying water is
wet and the sky is blue is like crazy
yeah but yeah this was black ice if
you're ever in Vegas stop by he has a
lot of a lot of guests on guys let me
know in the comments what do you think
should we expect monogamy from the top
10 20 of men or should we understand
that may come with it hope it doesn't
you know maybe just like maybe hope but
hope isn't reality uh make sure you go
subscribe to Christine's Channel I'll
like the video on your way out uh thanks
for coming Christine thanks for having
me here it's been definitely uh
eye-opening and somewhat infuriating but
that's what we're here to do that's what
we're here to do guys I'm going to
America so I'm not gonna have Pearl
daily for like 10 days so make sure you
tune in Christine's gonna have a lot of
content for you guys while we're gone
we've been filming this for a while so
we got a lot loaded up ready to go for
you guys like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel we'll talk to
you next time